dans son bilan rémy rebeyrotte met en
avant la fusion d'autun et de saint
pantaléon communes associées devenu
quartiers de la ville et plus largement
l'éclosion de l'intercommunalité il
évoque aussi la baisse de l'endettement
de près de deux millions sept cent mille
euros pourtant cette troisième campagne
n'est pas la plus facile la faute à la
multiplication des listes il y en a six
au total nous avons en face des
candidats qui ont commencé la campagne
par
ça va saigner
il faut tuer rebeyrotte aujourd'hui on
parle de guerre etc tout ça n'a pas de
sens nous sommes encore dans un pays où
nous n'avons pas à faire une guerre de
tranchées pour une campagne électorale
ce qui me paraît important c'est que dès
le premier tour les autunois vote pour
l'équipe et le maire qu'il souhaite voir
arriver en tête de l'élection au second
tour qu'il n'y ait pas de dispersion de
voix la diversité comme se plaît à la
nommer rémy rebeyrotte vient déjà de son
propre camp la gauche socialiste c'est
une constante est une nouvelle fois
divisée jean françois nicolas incarne
cette division il dénonce un
clientélisme devenu insupportable et une
concentration excessive des pouvoirs
dans les mains d'un seul et c'est
dommage parce que je pense que là la
mode de gouvernance très pyramidale très
centré sur un seul individu qui se veut
charismatique fini par créer des dérivés
à un espèce de clientélisme une une
obligation de passer toujours par
les fourches caudines d'un élu plutôt
que de faciliter la créativité la
complémentarité le partenariat honnête
sincère avec
ce clic sont les interlocuteurs normaux
d'une mairie sans famille politique
jacques perret vient se glisser entre la
droite et la gauche celui que certains
voient comme le coluche d'autun se
considère surtout comme un françois
bayrou punk ce patron d'une radio
associative refuse l'étiquette de
candidats fantaisistes et espère surtout
créer la surprise
c'est une possibilité que les autres
candidats n'entrevoit pas parce qu'ils
sont dans leur bus dans leur monde le
monde des partis politiques que nous
rejetons ils sont dans leur monde
bourgeois de l'othain d'hier lottin qui
a empêché le train l'autoroute d'arriver
sur autun moi je représente l'avenir
d'une part et puis je représente les
gens de tous les jours ce qui n'arrive
pas à payer leur loyer qui n'arrive pas
à se faire soigner les dents etc et ils
sont très nombreux sur autun donc les
autres candidats effectivement me
considère comme l'artiste un peu vos
rémy rebeyrotte a gagné matière
d'innocuité du champagne grâce à moi
parce que lui pensait que j'allais
monter manistes et son cabinet pensée
cno donc c'est amusant c'est bien à
droite rémy chanteuse gros et bertrand
jolie n'ont pas réussi à s'entendre pour
établir une seule liste ces deux
candidats ont pourtant un point en
commun ils veulent un avenir différent
pour la ville les reproches qui sont
ceux de l'accueil l'attractivité de la
ville qui est totalement perdu et le
manque d'accompagnement dans tous les
services ça c'est certain on se retrouve
aujourd'hui avec une ville qui a
complètement perdu son âme complètement
perdu son dynamisme et en emplois ça se
ressent ce que je changerais c'est cette
méthode
cette manière de faire qui en général
est plutôt destiné à à vouloir se faire
élire la prochaine fois et non pas
tournés vers les services qu attendent
les autunois on a dans un déclin à ces
terribles et tous les candidats
finalement veulent gérer avec la
on veut un renouveau pour autant on veut
un renouveau et on le prouve dire qu'on
a des méthodes nouvelles en politique le
maire le prochain maire ne sera pas
présent la communauté de communes si on
veut cottin se ressaisissent tu il faut
que ce soit deux personnes différentes
sauront ils s'entendre en cas de 2e tour
bertrand geôles il l'espère toujours à
rémy chanteuse rôle là dit il à une
liste complète qui n'a pas besoin
d'ajouts fin de citation